It's a road made of ice
and they truck on it.
Bullseye, that's the show,
plain and simple.
You twinks ready to do
some shots, pussies?
Oh-ho-ho, that's so hot,
I love girls like that.
Tequila,
no training wheels.
Burger, rare as (bleep).
Oh, yeah, a chick who can
really hang with the guys.
Yeah. That is the best.
A chick who's like super-hot,
but then like, loves Xbox,
down for pizza.
That tomboy thing,
you know?
Like, man,
I knew this girl, Joey.
That's a hot name right there.
That is a hot name.
Yeah, yeah, she was
off the charts, hot.
She could like beat me
in arm wrestling, you know?
That's like
my college girlfriend.
She was crazy hot.
She could recite all of
"Boondock Saints" verbatim
while building a deck,
she was ripped.
Murder him, God!
You know, I dated
a chick like that.
She was like, model hot,
plus she knew everything
about World War Two,
and she had
a super strong jaw.
She had like a lantern jaw.
Mmm.
Love that tomboy thing.
Hey, you know, she reminds me
of my ex, you know, real solid.
I could climb her like a tree.
She made me feel so safe.
I miss her.
Oh, man, there's this chick
at my office, right now.
I can talk to her
about Muay Thai.
Plus, she's got just like
a little bit of stubble.
(all)
Aah...
I need to hit that, man.
Yeah, you do.
That's the dream, right?
That's a fantasy,
like in "Rambo."
The main chick in that
with the headband, hot, right?
Yeah, no, man,
but there are real chicks
like that.
Like, I knew this girl Sam
when I lived in Tampa.
She was just naturally not,
like, rough hands, thick neck.
Forehead like a granite counter.
And she worked hanging drywall
for her dad's company,
Murphy and Son.
Yeah, she did.
Ooh, check it out.
(all)
Ohh...
My boner just got a boner.
My buddy, Goldman,
has this girlfriend, Glen.
She's like cover
of "Maxim" hot.
She does all those fantasy
football pics.
And she has like
this prominent dick.
I'm like, I want...
That's so (bleep) hot.
That is so (bleep) hot.
To chicks who can hang.
Yes.
Heading to the can.
Gotta make some room.
Ohh...
Wait, should we just
(bleep) each other?